oh now we're live well I guess we've
been live but you know how we start
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
[Music]
yo welcome back
in today's episode we're gonna be
talking about the NFL season I'm finally
gonna talk some sports
go talk to some AI news and I saw the
most adorable movie called Champions oh
man I gotta tell you about that
but other than that it's just a regular
week
it's me Aaron Griffin
and welcome back
[Music]
yay
I should add some water before I started
devote The Voice is not milky smooth
today y'all you know hey I do it live
sometimes
a little ASMR for you guys
I know some people hate that welcome
back to riffing with Griffin y'all
comedy podcast it's always 100 percent
me authentic I do it live off the cuff
my thoughts and ideas
um you know if you've been here before
you know what would know what we do if
you've never been here before and you're
like I thought this was your comedy
podcast sometimes it is sometimes I'm
serious but I'm always 100 me thanks for
coming as usual please uh subscribe hit
the Subscribe button y'all
subscribe
subscribe okay so hit that subscribe
button I'm on Twitch all the time so
check me out there I love Call of Duty
I'm playing that most of the time
and if you want to be uh you know extra
you could be on page you could be a
YouTube member a twitch member a twitch
subscriber or a patreon member to help
support the show I appreciate that as
always
and thank you for being here on riffin
with Griffo
um yeah I got a lot going on man uh this
week I uh gotta do you know I'm starting
this movie we got our sag waiver to like
you'll be an independent production uh
one of the last ones to get it so I
can't I'm excited about that that's
about to start
so I'll keep you posted on that man
um let's see I got shows coming up I'm
gonna be not this weekend but next week
I'm gonna be at the Orlando Improv for
one night and then Tampa Side Splitters
for the weekend uh for the you know so
make sure you come check me out in Tampa
and Orlando that's coming up uh it'll be
I'll have more stuff on the website but
you know you could go if you're in the
Orlando area you want to see me let's
let's sell that puppy out it's only one
night and then like I say I'll be uh two
nights at the Side Splitters in Tampa so
look for that
um this past weekend I was in Kansas
at the Kansas City Comedy Club and what
a good time I had really great time
the owner is tremendous
just a really good dude uh I can't I
can't say enough about Dustin
um just I just you know it's just you
know sometimes you go and you have a
really good experience I mean where I
was staying was not was a nice area uh
you know
I I appreciated that because that's a
lot of times that's that's half the
thing man
you know what I mean like half the the
the the thing when you're a comic they
always ask you like other Comics will be
like
um
you know hey uh how's the club you know
like how was the crowds and it's like
who cares the crowds are like it never
even matters because you know you're
always going to have for the most part
you're gonna have a good time at the
shows it's always the other stuff like
where are you staying uh how do they
treat you and it's just like and the
people of Kansas City were really great
but like if you get a chance to go out
to the Kansas City Comedy Club you
really should and the owner Dustin like
it's like we were like best friends
right away you know you got got in this
car where he picked me up and then we
just for a year yapping about stuff and
he's a single dad and you know and I'm
about to be a dad and it just we just
really hit it off so shout out to the
Kansas City Comedy Club uh good times
out there
um yeah guys uh nothing going on to
report uh Rachel's Trucking along you
know we're really looking pregnant
[Laughter]
which is good you know she's just like
uh I don't know it just makes me smile
every time I see the changes and it's
just knowing like what she's going
through and then like you know looking
at her like just knowing it there's a
baby growing in there is like amazing it
really is amazing so fingers crossed you
know everything is you know running
along smoothly but you know
I think there's two kinds of people
there's people with kids people without
kids you know and I'm in limbo but I'm
starting to see it's like it's like a
whole different thought process your
world is different it's like when you
people that got kids they want they're
looking in their neighborhood and
they're like what's going on with a Croc
why isn't there a crosswalk over here
what's going on here you know it's like
you start thinking about all that you
know you're thinking about like Hey
we're having speed bumps on the street
it's just weird how your mind starts to
go to like what
you know what it means to be a parent so
I've been looking forward to that it's
pretty exciting
um
shout out to shout out to all the trolls
out there thanks for trolling
I gotta I gotta look over because when
the trolls watch that's how they
you know my my screen will be up and
then they talk smack about me so I gotta
like give them a this will help you out
man
hahaha
trolls gonna troll appreciate that uh
you know whatever I need the views so I
love when the trolls watch and they put
their comments yo man you know it's like
thank you for the views I need them on
my little podcast
um what else is happening
not much man not much is going on man
you know I got I do want today want to
talk about like whatever the new the
news what's going on in AI this week a
lot of stuff going on with AI so we'll
get into that I want to get into my
football review of the season and I want
to review this movie Champions like I
said earlier in the intro but nothing
nothing uh nothing major to report man
um you guys uh and then let me um give
you a little you know let me put my q a
up and I want to thank everybody who
listens to the podcast too like you know
on Apple and all the places that you get
your uh podcasts
so I appreciate that I love the support
there and the comments you leave there I
appreciate that too so I put a little
question and answer up for the live
YouTubers if you uh have anything you
know just put it there and I will get
there eventually all right and so let's
get into what I like to do on the show a
lot is the comments you know let's get
to the prompt comments
um so I did put this one
uh video up from stand up and I always
get this comment the volume is too low I
didn't realize that so sorry thank you
you know I'm I'm gonna be aware I I
don't know why the volume was low on
that particular video I really don't
know why I don't know what I did wrong
there but I will figure that out but
thank you for letting me know
uh
uh let's see here
somebody said
dick jokes
and Bondo whatever what a dumb name new
mermaid new mermaid song be like
don't even understand that
somebody said common fool three two four
zero I know that uh okasaka
review is coming I don't know I don't
even know if I'm saying it right but
it's the new Star Wars show and yes it
is I just haven't started watching it
yet but I will I will get to I will I
will get to that you know like I said I
just haven't started watching the show
yet
um
you know there's a lot there's a lot of
there's so much entertainment and it and
it's like I just I just want to give it
I want to give it the proper
attention
you know because I hate getting to like
I always think like shows are like
relationships and you like you know what
I mean like you start watching them and
then like you know if it's like a good
show
it's like you want to finish it man you
know it's it's it's it really is a weird
thing all right I want to see there is
another show that I wanted to oh no I
didn't okay I finished that already yeah
because there's a couple of shows I'm
watching right now that I am going to
review in the future like one of them's
painkiller like man this is I don't know
if you know about the
you know it's like the Oxycontin
it's just the story of dad and the
company the something Pharma company
Purdue Pharma I believe it was and like
the opioid addiction and man what a show
that that is man I hate when they you
have like a fictionalized thing but they
also combining like in the middle of
each episode there's like or at the end
of the episode in the start of the
episode they have someone like a real
person being like hey this is how it
affected my life back then so it's like
that's something else
I am watching this other job just
letting you know what's coming in the
future so I'm watching painkiller I want
to give you the the scoop on that and
then I'm also watching
um
this show who is Aaron
who is Aaron something what is the name
of this show wait let me get it don't
you hate yeah who is Aaron Carter
so I don't know if I like it or not yet
but that's coming too all right back to
the comments
um
let's see
yeah so yeah I like sometimes I gotta
come here and I see people that need to
be removed foreign
let me tell you something I'm all about
a hide user from Channel you know what I
mean like I'd see you later it's like I
don't know why people think that we're
supposed to keep negativity in our life
like you don't we don't like you know
it's like this is my channel my podcast
for me and the whatever number of fans
that enjoy what I do and we just have a
conversation and there's so many people
that you know they come and they think
they like oh I'm gonna say some off
putting stuff on your page and think
that I'm gonna be like okay it's my
responsibility to keep that [__] you
know no I'm not I don't I don't have to
do that I don't care bye
I don't care if you live or die that's
how I think about that
all right so we got crypto is the way to
go I feel bad for this idiot
crypto man I'm sure oh man they don't
like to talk about all the money that
people have lost in crypto man it's
destroyed lives I think
I think Graham or Grant sounds great
talking about middle names that start
with G I'm sure there are a lot more to
come with that's probably even more
unique yeah we're I'm still coming up
with some G names because remember like
I said I want a name I want to have a g
name because of my middle name is G
Rachel's middle name is G so I want my
kid to have a middle name of G I want to
keep the tradition
um so I don't know we're still we're
still trying to uh come up with
something
uh
and then like what what's my guy oh this
guy wrote a lot of comments one credit
to your wife for working at Target
because she's probably she probably
wouldn't need to work at all if she
didn't want to yeah she don't got to
I don't even know if she's gonna go back
you know with all this with uh she's
actually been off
you know because of
how she's been feeling so I don't know
I told her she don't get sub to her
really if she don't want to she don't
got to
um
but whatever thanks thanks for that for
something positive finally
the the anti-target contingent is still
out there it's funny
uh let's see what we got here
um
okay oh that I always remember to come
through this uh yeah
there we go now we gotta we're you know
we're getting rid of another one
um let's see I had them all I should
look at these ahead of time right but I
actually like doing it live you know I
see something I go oh this is nice or
I'm like oh this sucks
um
okay let's see what oh somebody said the
movie field because the time travel
explanation was confusing and hard to
understand it didn't really have a point
to the movie superheroes are supposed to
save the world not mess it up with and
fix their mistakes oh the guy's talking
about the Flash
my opinion 5022 funny yeah you know what
I kind of thought that uh
I'm just saying the the mechanics of the
time travel in the flash I didn't like
it
I didn't think it was enough you know
sometimes you just need it just needs a
little bit a tweak to suspend your
disbelief and be like oh okay in the
movie in this movie Hero World I can
believe that that's how they time travel
right you just needed to make sense when
it doesn't make sense or or it just
makes you go yeah
and that was this one was just wonky and
the way he was running was like so dumb
I didn't like that
okay let's see
um Joel Jolie Adventures someone needs
to count how many times he says you know
what I mean per episode you know what I
mean
you're probably right
hit live you just kind of talking and
you know you take a pause
see I almost said it right there I'm
gonna I'm gonna try not to say it at all
today that was the only time I'm trying
to say it
ah
j739 Atlantic City oceans shows awesome
show Griff killed it thank you very much
um look here's more from crypto again
jeez this guy is all over the place
um somebody said DJ poo
T 2 IB I don't know you got to Market
more people will love you yeah I agree
these I think your podcast is incredible
as we get to know you you will have
loyal fans more people should do this
yeah I think you know I do I do want to
shout out to the
that's all the comments are today I do
want to shout out to like the loyal fans
I I do feel like I have a loyal fan base
like especially like on Twitch like the
Eric Griffin Gaming Community those guys
have been with me a lot of those guys
and girls have been with me since the
pandemic that's when I really started
doing that and then the people were
there and they were subscribing and we
were playing I was playing with them and
I did want to do custom matches by the
way but I can't do it today because I
have a fitting I wanted to do it today
but I have to go do this fitting right
after the podcast for the movie I'm
doing but anyways I do want to I
appreciate the fans and even the you
guys here too the the loyal Griffin with
Griffin people that come to the the live
every single week and you know what I'm
doing shows people do hit me up and
they're like hey man thank you
so that's that oh update on my car
Fisker you know I'm getting a Fisker
ocean
and I can't wait so
I was wondering what's going on I'm
seeing on their website on their
Instagram on Henry fisker's Instagram
and I follow this uh Fisker ocean uh
chat Group Forum that they are it's
called fiskarati and all they do is talk
about fiscal ocean
and I'm seeing these people have gotten
their cars so many people have gotten
their car
they're driving around L.A they're doing
meetups and I'm like where the hell is
my car so I went on Instagram and I like
put you know in my story hey I put the
picture of my the car from the thing and
I'm like where's my car you know I was
like hey can I get my car and I tagged
the owner of the company and I'm like
hey man you know so he followed he like
reposted that Fisker the the they
reposted and then they hit me up they
were like hey Eric uh you know can you
hit me up in the DMS and then I got a
call and I was like where's my you know
they were like we're gonna give you an
update on your car and they gave me an
update so then I got my financing thing
because I'm gonna lease I I bought my
Jaguar that I have so I have a Jag
i-pace
electric car fantastic car
my if it's a great car Jag makes a good
car
the EV part the electronics and all the
stuff it's kind of outdated it's not hip
and and I wish I would have leased to
the car because EV technology is going
to keep moving so fast that they're
going to get better and better so then
but you lose the value of the car man
that's the thing when you're getting
this new technology new type of car you
spend so much money for it it was
expensive car man the Jag and now I'm
probably oh man the like for three four
years I've had it it's like I'm trading
it in and believe me I'm losing so much
money but it is what it is you know you
have to think about like the value of
like what you're using it for and what
you got out of it I loved the Jag it's
great so now I'm gonna lease this for
sculpture so anyways
um now they said that when you you're
gonna get your car you're gonna like the
leasing process they'll send you this so
I got that too I got my lease
application so now that was approved and
I posted that like I almost got my car
and then they told me when the car was
coming and so then like you have to get
insurance and all this stuff because
everything's online now it's pretty
crazy processed the way you buy cars now
and all that so I even have a VIN number
for my car so I'm excited about that I'm
with one like I'm like a week or two
away from having my new car which I will
do a review of the Fisker ocean and I'm
getting a weird color with a with a
white interior you know
so
Yeah man so it's great like I say so I
see somebody in the chat uh electric
cars are a thing of the trash no man
they're great
like the comp the car companies now are
now they know they're they're making the
car that they already have they're just
making it electric and then there's all
these great technology in it you know
futuristic technology that's great so
whatever you know what I mean it's
tomato tomato whatever you like if you
like hearing like the you like hearing
that engine whatever if that's what your
thing is good for you but uh I'm never
gonna have a gas car again I love uh the
electric car and all that stuff
uh yeah living in La is expensive
somebody in chat said you know so yeah
so anyways I got that's my update about
my car let me go to the questions and
see if anybody asked a question somebody
said what did you think of Oppenheimer I
haven't watched it yet I don't know if I
will
um Colts Titans Jags who's going to win
the division I'm going to get to that
cause I'm talking football later uh
do you know the gender of your baby yes
we do I'm just not saying yet I did say
what am I saying it's a boy I already
said we already said it what am I
talking about hey Eric uh brother here
what do you think about the award zone
three I mean water more for three yeah I
will I will play it because Modern
Warfare 3 you know guys I play War Zone
all the time so the new version of the
the multiplayer game and campaign is
gonna come out I'm probably gonna get it
I'm probably not gonna play the campaign
the campaign's always useless who cares
I like playing against real people and
doing the war zone thing and ranking up
my guns in multiplayer so I am gonna get
it and I do think it's you know they did
put out a great product the war zone is
free to play it's a great product I
think I don't have no problem with the
company making money so you know I like
that
again another football question Chargers
team what you think uh have you and
Rachel decided on any parenting
techniques no but we are looking in a
lot of we it's like there's a lot of
information out there and I think the
internet is a great source of that you
know even like things like Tick Tock and
Instagram so many of these like you know
new mom or baby tip uh things there's so
many you know you're and then you know
you can sift through all that and figure
out which one is
what you want you know or what you know
what speaks to you I don't think
anyone's ready to have a kid
that's what they say who's really ready
but you just do it and another another
message I see a lot of is
parenting is really hard
for great parents
because you're doing all of these you're
going above and beyond uh with your like
emotions and
how you're supposed to react to like
this little monster
you know be new to the world and doesn't
even know how to handle its own emotions
and everything so I'm really like
looking forward to seeing how that will
change me so but anyways we're here for
it we're all here for it right we're all
here for it all right uh you know one of
the things I wanted to talk about I was
in um when I was in Kansas City you know
I'm in the car with someone you know
when the car with the owner we're
driving someplace get into the left hand
turn lane
it is a bicycle a guy on a bike in the
left-hand turn lane
I can't stand this
you were not a car
I don't care about the law like they
always have these dumb laws why would
you want to be on a bike in traffic with
two three ton
cars driving around you like you just
this is a recipe for death
and then why especially in the left turn
lane what you doing in the left turn
lane man
just go like the traffic's going this
way left and right and you're in the
left turn lane just get in the cross go
just go in the crosswalk I mean like you
know what I mean oh I said I said it all
right well that's one time I said it I
didn't mean to say it but I said it
I said who I am Let Me Be Me
you know what I mean there another one
get out of the crosswalk
get out of the left turn lane if you
want to bicycle
that is super annoying
hate it
anyways
some weird Instagram stories of the week
this one I thought was like super weird
man pleads guilty to having sex with a
cow in England
yeah
what are you doing bro
what are you doing
you want to have sex with a cow why
and then who caught him I wish I knew
more about this story
I mean it's like
imagine having to go to court
you're in court
and you have to
they maybe because you know in this day
and age people be filming
you know you're in somebody's Farm
just giving it to this cow
and it's like is it like Cowie style too
I don't know what with the proper con
term be
it's just you know
and then you have to now you get
arrested and you in court and the
lawyers like look they got you on tape
there's like five witnesses
so you might as well just plead guilty
to this
and then
you know you're just I mean the public
shame of it is probably I don't even
what what even happens
to I I wish I would like I should almost
look that up like what's the crime
what's the you know what let's go to the
AI I bet you the AI
what should the AI will tell me you know
there's there's some great AIS let's go
to perplexity and ask the AI here we go
guys this is perfect
all right
um wait oh here it is ask it anything
what is the punishment for having sex
with a cow in England
all right let's see what it says
oh it has a whole
yeah it's great here we go guys having
sex with an animal including a cow is
illegal in England and is considered an
act of animal cruelty
animal cruelty I mean
maybe you hitting it right though what
if that Cadillac
cow's like are you hitting ass spot what
if you see the guys the cows I go oh
yeah keep going so I don't know if it's
group but I guess it's cruelty and how
can it be cruelty unless it's like like
how big how big is this guy's dick how
cruel is it you know
cooler than like you know what's crazy
about this this is what I find the
hypocrisy of this is like so you can
kill the cow for steak
get it pregnant steal the baby drain all
the milk
that's fine
but don't [__] it
that's just it just seems it just seems
hypocritical
it just seems hypocritical you know
maybe maybe the cows enjoying it I don't
know
probably not though I mean it's because
a cow like how can the cow give consent
here we go there's then that's gonna be
the whole thing you know
all right the punishment for having sex
with a cow in England depends on the
severity of the offense and can range
from from a fine to imprisonment the
severity of the offense how do you
determine the severity of what you're
doing with the cow like it may is it
like if they if they have you on tape
and you're just like get you know you're
just pounding away is that like the
severity of it but you're slapping's ass
how do you how do you determine the
severity of this maybe you're you know
are you whipping it or something like
what if you what what if you're in court
and it's like that your your attorney
was like your honor my client uh was
making gentle passionate love to this
cow so can we please just go with a fine
so I don't know how they determine the
severity
so here's this guy in the case of Liam
Brown who recently pled guilty to having
sex with a cow in England the case has
been transferred to the Crown Court for
sentencing and magistrates have
suggested that he may be facing a
custodial sentence the maximum sentence
for sexual penetration with a living
animal and causing unnecessary suffering
to a to a protected animal is two years
in prison
wow man
hey
don't know what we learned is
don't have sex with a cow
all right the other story is this one
which I thought was like what are we
talking about
so this guy Jonathan chiban
he filed a 20 million dollar lawsuit
he claims a sauce bottle sliced his hand
so he broke a sauce bottle
um you know and
this is what happened
let's see what uh the AI has to the
information it can get so Jonathan
cheeben I don't even know who this is
you know uh
you know I don't even know what
I don't even know what he does
so Jonathan achievement also known as
the food God and friend of Kim
Kardashian wow imagine that's one of
your credits
you're so famous that being friends with
someone is a credit has father 20
million dollar lawsuit against a Korean
barbecue sauce company according to
court documents he claims that a bottle
of Sanjay's Korean barbecue sauce sliced
his hand causing injury the incident
reportedly occurred while he was making
a meal in Miami
so let me get this straight
you making a meal probably recording it
for your your your
Channel or whatever you not paying
attention
and you break the bottle and then it you
you get cut
and you think that's worth 20 million
dollars what is this guy got a bionic
implant who does this guy like why 20
million dollars
how is his hand worth 20 million dollars
my goodness
he got 20 million dollar hand man
I think I want him I think I need that
uh I need I think I need that hand job
you know if you got a twist I wonder
what that would feel like he's like he
got a 20 it better be a magic hand for
20 million dollars
the details of the lawsuit such as
specific injuries sustained and the
legal arguments being made are not
provided in this search result so
this
is crazy okay absolutely batshit crazy
all right y'all let's get into what I
wanted to get into today let's talk
about the NFL season right
let's get into the NFL season wait let
me get my uh where's my NFL pick oh here
it is you do that you do this yes y'all
I've been playing fantasy football for
like 20 years I don't know if you guys
play Fantasy Football but you know I
love fantasy football it's like you know
I've been with the same guys it's like
crazy with like how people have grown
they got kids you know they've changed
jobs they moved there's so much stuff
going on in my fantasy football league
but I love those guys
but
um this year I feel like this is gonna
be one of the most exciting
seasons
in NFL
in the
NFL in a very long time
you know
um
the divisions are so like the AFC is so
stacked man
you know
wow let me see here
you know I think that like the the NFC
if we start with the NFC so you got the
Eagles okay so the Eagles are coming
back they made a lot of changes they
lost players but they drafted well they
had a lot of good backups last year
they're now going to become starters
they got a lot of all they got all Pros
all over the field and Jalen hurts is
now going to be in this I believe fourth
season he was already runner-up for the
MVP last year and he balled out in the
Super Bowl so you gotta think that that
the NFC
favorite is that the Eagles from the you
know from the NFC East okay that's uh
you know you got the Eagles
you got the Eagles the Giants the
Cowboys who else is in that division
Eagles Giants Cowboys I'm missing
someone
that is really gonna be oh and the
Washington team
and I don't know how they're gonna be
this year but you know the um
man
the the the NFC so like the three I
think that the top teams are gonna be
the Eagles San Francisco 49ers
can the Brock party you know Mr
Irrelevant except the the last pick in
the draft last year comes in wins like
seven games seven out of eight games
balls out multiple two touchdown games
very few interceptions the team rallied
around him and you know he got hurt in
the NFC Championship Game
yeah the Eagles took him out you know
that's part of their job defense went in
heard him
then they hurt the second the next
quarterback they had no one we don't
know we were robbed of a great game last
year so maybe we'll get that this year
from all accounts in preseason Brock
Purdy is looking good coming off that
elbow surgery
so we'll see if this San Francisco 49ers
and they still have a stellar defense
and they have a great offense like their
offense it's great Mike Shanahan he can
take really any quarterback and make him
good he just couldn't do that with Trey
Lance who was traded to the Dallas
Cowboys I think the Dallas Cowboys have
a stacked team from top to bottom I'm
not a Dallas Cowboys fan but they are
looking good the one question they have
and it's the question they've had for
the last seven years Dak Prescott can
Dak Prescott finally
lead his team to the NFC championship
and to the Super Bowl and win it I don't
know it doesn't seem like he can because
in previous years the Dallas Cowboys
have lost because of him they had a
tremendous defense last year even in a
game where the 49ers
um
didn't have
remember when they played like the 49ers
didn't have a
like you know quarterback they had they
they held them that's what I'm saying
you know when Dad when they played that
they played Dallas last year right yeah
they did
um anyway my point is
the the Dallas Cowboys like is this the
writing on the wall for Dak Prescott
I'm hearing a lot of different reports
because one Dak Prescott has two years
left on his deal right now this is very
interesting he got two years left on his
deal
um he has a no trade clause and he has a
no franchise tag Clause he'll be 31
years old when he ends his contract if
he plays just
decent he might get a another big
contract or he'll be put into free
agency but there'll still be some team
out there that'll sign him because they
need a quarterback so who knows but
anyways my point is you got the
San Francisco 49ers Dallas Cowboys
Eagles I think that's the top three in
that in the NFC and then everything else
is just you know gravy like every every
other team is just kind of like there we
don't know what they're gonna do you
know you got the Rams are they what's
going to happen with them they're young
they traded away everything they're not
looking good Tampa Bay has Baker
Mayfield as their quarterback they have
a great defense but who knows what's he
gonna do okay can he can he be a
quarterback uh you know we got love
what's his name the the new quarterback
for the Green Bay Packers they still
have a solid team great receivers good
young receivers great running game they
had a really great defense towards the
end of the year but Ken Jordan loved be
the the next great quarterback for the
Green Bay Packers so who knows what's
even going to happen in that division in
that conference uh Minnesota Vikings
same thing Kirk Cousins he's just he's
like Dak Prescott they're like the same
player really good can take their team
to 12-13 wins but when it when crunch
time comes who knows but Minnesota lost
Dalvin cook Diamond Cook's not there
anymore
he was a big checkdown passed the ball
to him for six yards he would go for 30.
when Jefferson's not open pass it down
to him the running game was solid I
don't know what's going to happen when
Minnesota they were a good team but do
they do they even have a chance I don't
know you got young teams like Chicago
Bears with their Young quarterback
Justin Fields they got him a bunch of
weapons but are they really a contender
I don't think so you know um let's see
like I said Tampa the Cardinals their
quarterback is out and they and they're
looking to tank the season so they could
get uh then that Caleb Williams from USC
the New York Giants they had a great run
last year new coach really good coach
they he got him to the playoffs you know
uh their quarterback Daniel Jones had
the best year of his career of his
career but it was still pedestrian he's
a running quarterback
so who knows how what the Giants are
gonna do and then you got the Saints
with uh what's his name Derek Carr
you know Derek Carr's won one playoff
game in his whole career so we'll see
what he does you know it's like
I don't know guys we will see what's
going on there man so it's like it's
it's hard to even determine what's going
on in the NFC now let's talk about the
AFC
um
the AFC is just looking so stacked man
Kansas City of course Patrick Mahomes
best player in the league five times to
the end AFC Championship game three
times to the Super Bowl two Super Bowl
championship wins if the offensive line
doesn't hurt they might have had three
they might have beat the the Brady's
Tampa Bay but who knows but you got to
put them they're the cream of the crop
right cream of the crop but even still
we don't know they they they're always
changing receivers when they lost
Highway kill we didn't think they would
be able to win and they did they still
won so Kansas City Chiefs looking strong
but check this out then you got the Jets
what's gonna happen with them Aaron
Rodgers is with the Jets they got up
they got Dalvin cook off free agency
they got that priest Holmes pre not
priest Holmes priests whatever his last
name is he's he was the Rookie of year
running back candidate he got hurt he
was on his way to be the Rookie of the
Year he got hurt they got that great
received young receiver who was
offensive rookie of the year so they got
they're gonna have two Stellar running
backs dogs they're gonna have a great
number one receiver and they got a bunch
of dudes serviceable you got Aaron
Rodgers and you got a stellar defense so
you got Kansas City you got the Jets
Ravens
uh Lamar Jackson's not hurt back but
they got him weapons they got a new
offensive coordinator there he's got the
second best winning record since he's
been in the league what are the Ravens
gonna do man it's like you know
um
hold on a second look I want to get all
these teams right AFC uh
uh AFC division let me get it to me
because I had it up in my my thing
closed
okay so anyways all right let's go down
let's go down the line here okay so in
the AFC East let's go AFC East you got
Buffalo they're still good can Josh
Allen take his team over the edge I
don't know they had that stuff in the
preseason with Stefan Diggs who knows if
they're still going to be a good team so
you got Buffalo Bills New York Jets
Miami Dolphins Tua Tunga full over Tanga
Lova whatever his name is he's back
after the concussions
I pray this kid could still play
because they have a great team they had
a decent defense and they got these two
dogs two number one receivers Tyree kill
and waddle on the outside I believe
that's his name right the other guy
they were he was going for 2 000 yards
last year he was ready to ball out Tyree
kill they're looking good in that
Division and then of course the New
England Patriots probably the worst team
in that division can but but
Bill Belichick he's good for a couple of
spoiler wins for some of these teams
that division stacked so at least three
of those teams should be playoff teams
right
then you go to the AFC North Cleveland
with all the DeSean Watson nonsense with
the allegations and everything he's
finally have playing a full season with
that fully guaranteed contract
excuse me
it's time for him to show up they have a
good team they're got a playoff caliber
team Baltimore Ravens playoff caliber
team like I talked about Cincinnati
Bengals they've already been to the
Super Bowl in the AFC Championship three
times now they mentioned the Super Bowl
once AC Championship three times they're
ready that that quarterback is just a
monster Joe burrow monster they're a
playoff team and Pittsburgh Steelers
they are a playoff team Mike Tomlin has
never had a losing season in his whole
career the guy the the quarterback I
think his name is Kenny Pickett is that
right guys uh forgive me if I'm messing
up the names but he's looking good in
preseason their defense is great they
got some young receivers and young
running backs they're ready to go they
got some veterans they got a good mix of
veterans and and the guys one of the
best coaches in the league you're
talking about four teams in the AF AFC
North who potentially could be playoff
teams only six teams make the playoffs I
just want to point that out to you I've
already said one two three four five six
seven eight there's already
seven teams and we haven't even got to
the AFC South okay ABC South weakest
division in the AFC Jacksonville made
the playoffs last year Trevor Lawrence
balling out
come on that guy they're they're
probably the best team in that division
Tennessee Titans they still got Derrick
Henry can they with Tana Katana Hill in
them remember they were like number one
in the AFC three years ago they could
potentially be a playoff team again and
then you go to the AFC West
stacked again Denver Broncos new coach
Sean what's his name uh
um what's his from the Saints you know
can he turn Russell Wilson's career
around they could be a playoff team
Kansas City we already know they're
going to be in the playoffs the Chargers
man is it time for the Chargers to step
up they got that guy they got Kellen
Moore from the doubt from um Dallas
Cowboys their their offensive
coordinator who was the number one
offense for two years in a row Dallas
Cowboys they got that offensive
coordinator now for Justin Herbert this
freaking Zoid quarterback handsome dude
6'5 rocket arm accuracy could do all the
you know all the plays that anybody can
make it's time for them they are
potentially a playoff team dude the AFC
is stacked
Sean Payton thank you AFC is stacked so
I am I have never looked forward to NFL
season more than this one right now like
this is going to be a tremendous NFL
season I can't wait to talk about it all
year so all you people that don't know
Sports just follow along with me I'll
give you the cliff notes but it's
looking good I don't have a favorite yet
for either the only favorite I would say
is I would pick the NFC favorite and I
think I think that
I think I don't even know man I can't
even say but if I had to pick when my my
heart out I think the 49ers are gonna
finally make the jump I think they I
think they they have a chip on their
shoulder I think they felt like they had
a great team last year and then just
injuries for their quarterback messed
them up but I think with a full season
with Brock Purdy that defense is great I
see the 49ers going to the Super Bowl
and in the AFC I'm just gonna pick my
heart I want to see Aaron Rodgers in the
Super Bowl I think 49ers versus the Jets
would be a great Super Bowl but who
knows man you know what I mean it could
be anybody it could be anybody but we
will see what happens there uh but
anyways that's uh my talk my Super Bowl
talk for my Super Bowl NFL talk for now
just a little preview
um yeah it's gonna be
what a season man I mean I'm telling you
I like I hope it lives up to
expectations with all of these teams man
all the great like all the great
quarterbacks in the AFC Justin Herbert
uh you know Patrick Mahomes uh Trevor
Lawrence
um
there's just so many
Aaron Rodgers uh uh Joe burrow uh what's
his name from the bills Josh Allen like
there's so many great quarterbacks
in the AFC so look out for that
all right I want to do a quick movie
review listen man this was an absolute
adorable movie Rachel's sitting there
watching this movie and she was like
watch it with me you know because she
was like feeling pregnant and whatnot
and the movie's called champions
and it stars Woody Harrelson just let me
just read you the things you know what
it's about a former minor league
basketball coach is ordered by the court
to manage a team of players with
intellectual disabilities he soon
realizes that despite his doubts
together his team can go further than
they ever imagined so you can imagine
yourself what this movie but it's a you
know it's actually a really it's a good
feel-good movie
um with a lot of great messages in it
and if you're like if you like to cry
when you watch movies because of like
moments and feel good things I this is a
really nice watch you can see it on
Amazon it's an Amazon movie Amazon Prime
movie so if you have Prime you could
just watch it it's a fun watch man Woody
Harrelson is like he's so like it's such
a likable guy that you know he plays it
well you know it's like what you would
think
you know if they're not jamming this
down your throat you know what I mean I
said you know what I did it again I
think I said it five times in this
episode we'll count
it's just one of those they I think it I
think it was well done I do
it's like instead of
adding this
what I like about this is like it's not
like you have like hey let's do Peter
Pan and just add uh here's someone with
Down Syndrome on you know are you you
know just to try you're trying to like
oh look how special and woke we are as
opposed to like hey let these guys have
their own movie and that's what it was
all the characters were great they were
funny and it was just uh it was a
heartfelt movie and I'm giving it eight
woo-woos
[Music]
so make sure you guys check out
Champions I won't spoil it for you but
you can imagine how it ends
but even with all that I'm telling you
even with all that
it's it it's it's a really good
feel-good movie
I enjoyed it tremendously man
um all right and then I'm gonna finish
off with like I haven't talked about AI
in a while so there's some good websites
that have like one of them is the
independent in UK and they have this
like great like there's always these
great headlines about AI man and what's
coming uh
like one of the things that's great is
this AI powered drug implant
revolutionary for chronic conditions
like some of the things they're using
the AI for in the medical field it's
like extending people's lives and
helping people like walk again and maybe
it's going to help people with learning
disabilities maybe it's going to help
people like you know who knows but you
know
it's crazy man
um AI found and then like this is what
I'm saying too like the AI is is now
able to detect things like look at that
look at this someone right there AI
found to detect Parkinson's up to seven
years before symptoms like that kind of
stuff is like we have to change our
world so whatever you think about Ai and
of course the you know the movie
versions of it is is that there's always
the worst possible thing but you know
you got to think of it like any sort of
any sort of like technology can be used
for for bad you know you have the
internet you have all the things that
are bad about the internet and you know
the black the what is it like the dark
web and you know trying to hire a hitman
and all that kind of dark stuff of the
internet but let's not forget of like
equally and probably more positive
things people can do with it uh you know
so this is just an example
of one of one of those things man you
know they just have so much
you know police catch 300 drivers
breaking the law in three days using AI
I mean so like man you know it's like
it's like are they going to be referees
in sports anymore are we gonna like is
they're gonna have like all these
cameras on an NBA basketball game and
there will be no need to have a referee
you know just like be a guy in front of
a monitor and the AI will be like foul
and then you know and then maybe they
could turn it up or down based off you
know do it like do we want to take the
human element out of everything probably
not there are some things that you want
you don't want a soulless just
methodical mathematical machine deciding
things for human beings but it is a tool
that I think
we have to somehow find a middle ground
to incorporate into our lives
uh but some of this stuff is just really
great
um
you know I just I feel bad for graphic
designers I feel bad for like people
that do that stuff because there's so
many of these apps man where you just it
says to you type what you're looking for
and you know you put in you know you put
into the the the the AI uh you know
create
uh you know Pippi Long stockings
um
Metallica
whatever just you know whatever you know
what I mean like whatever you your heart
can imagine Halloween costume or oh oops
sorry that's not what I meant to do
um
um and then the next thing you know it
comes up with this really graphic art
and you're like oh man what about what's
like what are artists doing
so even if you're an artist now like
what are you getting using it as
inspiration are you like you're saying
Hey I want to uh three babies three
babies in a pumpkin patch and then
you're getting that and then like you're
painting it yourself I just just don't
know what this means for creativity and
how it's going to be used and stimulated
in our lives so it's really amazing
uh all of the different things that
error AI like that one right there
paralyzed man regains feeling and
movement with AI brain implant you know
just all that stuff AI can read breast
cancer screening images the study finds
and so you know for every I'm sure right
now there's probably equally amount
there's probably an equal amount of
crazy stories as there are
great as there are terrible stories
about AI so we'll just have to see where
it goes from here you know we'll just
have to see man
um
so we'll see
so send me some more of those G names
guys if people still want to like which
I'm still trying to decide what's a good
G name for the middle name for the baby
uh you know so we're looking forward to
that you know we're at like nine eight I
think we're at like 18 19 weeks right
now so we're Trucking along uh that
that's uh I don't know it's just like I
say it's really exciting you know all
you parents out there you know you can
send me some tips and advice and
you know like well how was it for you
and uh as a newborn
with having a newborn as a new dad as a
new mom as a new parent what did it make
you think uh what that was how hard was
it uh you know what what here's a here's
the thing I really want in the comments
what would you do differently like if
you're a parent and you said I had to go
back when my newborn was here oh I wish
I would have done what
so let me know
uh oh I see somebody in the chat said
pork chop Express AI will take over fast
food places for sure because at least
hey I will get the orders right and have
everything made fresh yeah who knows
what it's gonna you know what I mean
that's actually an interesting thought
man uh I just I don't know man I don't
know
but anyways
you know what time it is guys I
appreciate you guys being here as always
every single week
so make sure
you uh
make sure you uh you know subscribe
hit that twitch
hit that patreon
appreciate y'all yeah once again
it's that rap recap
everybody hit the clap
you're getting slapped on the booty like
a pop
got
[Music]
NFL preview I thought you knew
AMC
it's better than the rest
all right rap recap is whack this week
but I just like this beat
that beat moving
[Music]
anyways guys thanks for watching Ripper
with Griffin and I will see you
next week appreciate you thanks again
and goodbye
foreign
[Music]